thank you to LastPass for sponsoring a
portion of this video hey everyone how's
it going my name is mayuko and welcome
back to my channel where we talk about
Tech Career and life so today we're
going to talk again about coding boot
camps for those of you who are
unfamiliar you may ask what are coding
boot camps coding boot camps are short
and intensive programs to learn software
engineering skills with the ultimate
goal of getting a job they're a great
accelerated way to get into software
engineering without needing to go
through a four-year degree program at a
university they vary in duration but
typically are around 12 weeks long and
demands about 40 to 60 hours a week of
work that was from a previous video
where I talk about what coding boot
camps are if you haven't watched it
already I'll leave a link in the card
Right Above So today we're specifically
going to be talking about how to choose
a coding bootcamp deciding to go to one
is already a big life decision so
choosing which one to attend is a huge
first step and there's a lot of things
to consider I have actually never going
through the experience myself so I
interviewed a few people who did to give
Insight on the important factors to
consider when choosing a boot camp and
before we Dive Right In I wanted to say
thank you to LastPass for sponsoring
this portion of the video so I hope we
all know that in order to peruse the
internet in a safe and secure way you're
supposed to use different passwords for
every single site that you log into well
LastPass relieves a burden of generating
and remembering those passwords with
LastPass you don't have to write
remember or reset passwords LastPass
also autofills your credentials on
mobile sites and apps for IOS and
Android when you open an app or site
LastPass will fill in your username and
password for you making it fast and easy
to log in features include unlimited
password storage free cross device sync
and password sharing so click the link
below and start using LastPass today
thank you to LastPass for sponsoring
this portion of the video and now let's
get back to coding boot camps so first
let's talk about boot camps in 2020.
according to a few market reports about
boot camps they have campuses in over 85
cities across the United States and
Canada 83 of boot camp grads report
being employed in programming jobs the
average starting salary is around 67 000
across the United States which varies a
lot depending on your location on
average the tuition for in-person boot
camps is around 13 500 and they're about
15 weeks long and finally online boot
camps have seen enormous growth of about
171 percent which I imagine is even more
now because of coven 19. so our coding
bootcamps still a viable solution for
changing careers into technology well
the statistics show that the number of
boot camp graduates are increasing year
over year so most bootcamps really
aren't going anywhere anytime soon but
on an individual basis I'm learned that
it really depends on your personal
situation personally like I think it
comes down to opportunity costs I think
nowadays there's a lot of online
resources so if you're extremely
disciplined and maybe you've been doing
this for the last six months and you
could see yourself improving week over
week and month over month I would say go
as far as you can using online free
resources the biggest thing is to
consider is how do you get a job in Tech
the quickest right so if you can do it
on your own using online resources great
that could be a great option for you but
if studying on your own is gonna result
in you spending 12 to 18 months
struggling you're probably better off
doing a part-time course or South based
course that's six months long even if
you get a job three months quicker than
doing online that opportunity cost of
getting paid three months earlier will
already pay for itself so that's kind of
like how I would think about like
whether to do it online for free or
whether to sign up for a boot camp if
you're finding yourself where you're
getting stuck a lot in those cases
bootcamps do help because they give you
that structure you also see other people
around you struggling which is actually
I think Super underrated because when
you're learning on your own you might be
struggling you think you're the only
person that's having these issues and I
think that's closely linked to the
Imposter syndrome as well where you
think this is only happening to you but
everyone else around you is fully on top
of their game once you actually do a
boot camp you realize that everyone has
a hard time everyone struggles but
that's part of that Journey so once you
figure out that it's the right solution
for you how do you go about choosing
which one to attend well one of the most
important factors to consider is to
think about how you're going to sustain
yourself while you attend the boot camp
like what's your lifestyle gonna be like
do you need to keep making income while
you're attending or do you have a
savings that you can lean on can you
afford your living expenses especially
if you're gonna move to a new city and
how many hours a week can you devote to
the boot camp with a lot of folks in
career Karma they're opting in for
either part-time or self-paced
especially for working adults very few
people can take three months off to just
do a boot camp so if you're going to be
doing a part-time option figure out
whether it's going to be nights and
weekends or if it's going to be more
stuff based and flexible because that's
going to make a difference if you're
going to be signing up for the next six
to 12 months to do a boot camp make sure
that you're not over stretching yourself
especially if you have kids and family
you want to make sure that you're
balanced and you can actually complete
it an entire commitment like can you
actually commit to this doing this boot
camp because I know there's a lot of
people in the boot camp they think
they're able to do it and then they come
into the boot camp and they're like whoa
this is like a lot of work definitely if
you have the time then do it if you
don't have the time I would kind of
reconsider you will be spending a lot of
late nights doing doing a bunch of
research they're not there to teach you
everything they're there to teach you
how to get that information you know how
to Google is definitely like the number
one skill for boot camp and one of the
big factors around this decision is to
think about what city you want to attend
the boot camp in now I know we're in
kind of a weird time because of covid-19
but pre-pandemic boot camps were most
plentiful in areas that have a tech Cub
like San Francisco or New York City it's
not uncommon for people to move to these
Tech hubs just to attend boot camps
since it's likely going to be where
they'll find jobs too but for some a big
move or a commute to one might not make
sense are you able to like go out of
your way to like go to this boot camp
like if it's like an hour away but you
live in socau that's going to be
probably like two hours instead like is
this worth it for you is it worth it to
drive every day to your boot camp like
can you can you do that can you commit
to that so I looked at some other ones
um like hack reactor General Assembly
the downside with that one was it was
too far for me I live in Anaheim SoCal
traffic is like horrendous so I didn't
want to drive all the way to La for a
hack reactor or assembly or like Pomona
so that was kind of out of the question
for me but I learned interestingly that
it might be to your advantage to to
attend a boot camp that's not in a tech
Hub what we're finding is that people
and secondary like Tech markets are
actually having an easier time finding a
job because there's less competition a
lot of companies are open to hiring
Junior Talent whereas the main markets
like San Francisco New York La Chicago
there is more saturation of bootcamp
grads looking for applying for jobs so
then you have to do more to stand out in
your interview processes another big
factor to
L is the cost of the boot camp because
boot camps are not cheap they might
range anywhere from two thousand dollars
to thirty thousand dollars so a lot of
people don't have that kind of big money
lying around but the good news is each
boot camp has different offerings on how
you can pay you can always pay upfront
in cash but there's some creative
financing options that enable you to
afford it without breaking the bank one
of the common ones is deferred payments
that's where you don't need to pay the
boot camp until you get your first job
there's also income sharing where a boot
camp takes a percentage of maybe your
first one to three years worth of your
salary the cool things about income
sharing is that there's minimum salary
requirements so if you don't make above
a certain threshold you don't have to
pay even if you get your job most isas
have a maximum you'll have you'll have
to pay out and usually it's about thirty
thousand so for most schools you're not
going to pay more than 30k even if
you're making 200 000 as your first job
but overall ask your boot camps if they
have living stipends that's something
that has come up and if you live in
Atlanta I think San Francisco Denver you
might be eligible for some living Stipe
and so ask your boot camp if they have
that tuition for UCI you can do it
multiple ways you can pull out a loan
you go through that whole loan
processing you have multiple ways to pay
off your loan in order you can pay
monthly uci's program was around 12 000.
what I learned from my other boot camp
members was that some of them already
have like career jobs and then some of
their companies are actually willing to
invest in them and be like hey if you
want to do this boot camp you can do it
once you complete it to show your
certificate and then we'll pay for like
half of it depending on what your
starting salary is if you choose
something like income sharing then it
can determine how much money you end up
paying back to the boot camp look at the
market you're in because if you're in a
competitive market and there's a lot
there are a lot of companies hiring and
maybe the average salaries are like
within the range where even if you're
paying back a percentage of your income
you're still going to be in a solid
middle class bracket I think that makes
sense but with some um markets if you're
going to be making a 50k or 55k if
that's the average and then you have to
factor in that you're going to be paying
an additional 15 20 income sharing
before tax that might be pretty
burdensome so you should definitely look
into your average salary rates when
you're evaluating the boot camps one
thing to note there if you choose the
financing option is that boot camps will
perform background and credit checks on
you to make sure that you can pay them
back if you're going to be doing
financing boot camps have different
background check requirements and credit
history requirements we recommend people
to apply to at least two to three
different schools there's folks that
apply to one school they're super
excited and then they get turned down
because they have maybe they have like a
late theme and a loan from six six years
ago we tell them not to give up because
every school has their own credit
requirements and if you don't get into
one there's probably at least one or two
other boot camps that will accept you
now after you figured out some of the
big factors that go into deciding a boot
camp it's time to do some more in-depth
research to find out what the actual
experience will be like you might be
able to find a lot of information on a
boot camp website but boot camp grads
recommend that you talk to past
attendees to get the real scoop on how
it was doing your research on these boot
camps like understanding what they give
I've had a lot of people reach out to me
on LinkedIn like just asking about the
boot camp if you can't find any more
resources on the website itself then
reach out for people on LinkedIn see if
they put their school in their LinkedIn
and just reach out to them ask them like
hey like what did you think about this
boot camp do you think it was worth it
and then if you can't get more
information like just call the school
ask them like you know can I get a
curriculum can you give me more
information I'm really highly
considering this I just want more
information and they'll more than likely
give you the information they'll give
you like for me they gave me the
curriculum and they went into detail
like this is what you're gonna be doing
across these weeks and this is what
you're going to learn if this is
something that you want to do then sign
up uh so I I mainly ask them you know
how was the job searching process after
attending the boot camp yeah and I asked
them you know how long it took them to
find a job what it was like if they if
the boot camp offered you any services
for help you know people were really
open about sharing their experiences so
what might you ask when you're talking
to past boot camp grads well one
important thing could be job placement
each boot camp may or may not offer some
job placement help after all the
coursework is done from resume reviews
to networking events to interview prep
but what's important is whether you're
actually able to land a job afterwards
at all a lot of my statistics I looked
up the kind of placement rates for those
specific boot camps and also average
salary coming out of those boot camps
because I knew that if I was going to be
spending this much money I wanted to
definitely see results or maybe it's the
network and Prestige that get you more
opportunities there are other boot camps
around Irvine too that I looked into but
it didn't seem like it was as
prestigious when I was talking to the
UCI person they're like yeah this is a
fairly new program but once you complete
it you're going to be part of like the
UCI Network which I am now because when
you put that on your on your LinkedIn a
lot of people are gonna like look you up
from Irvine now the last two factors to
consider are around learning styles each
boot camp runs their program a little
little differently and hires your own
instructors to teach the class some boot
camps are all online While others meet
in person we always recommend folks to
consider like the teaching style and
your personal learning style and make
sure that that corresponds some folks
prefer in-person instruction some folks
are more free spirit and like to do
things remotely definitely like Azure
evaluating bootcamps check out if they
have an online option available or if
they have in-person only classes so
that's usually a big factor and while
most boot camps have some sort of
interview process to admit you into the
program some don't have a screening
process at all which means that anyone
is welcome but the coursework might not
be as rigorous as you want it to be a
downside with some of these boot camps
is that there's no like screening
process you know I know certain programs
they have a screening process to to see
like are you going to be able to do this
with my bootcamp there there was no
screening process so we did have people
like they had no back background in Tech
whatsoever and they kind of just like
wanted to jump into this we kind of had
to cater to them a bit so like the pace
kind of slowed down and we couldn't
cover as much as we could don't get me
wrong like like it's it's totally cool
like it was just a downside because like
there are some of us in the boot camp
that are a little bit more advanced and
we wanted to really get like an
accelerated course and get to learn more
and more and more so there you have it
all the important factors on deciding
which boot camp to attend thank you to
our guests David arter and Jason for
being on the channel and sharing their
experiences today if you attended a boot
camp then let me know what your
experiences have been and what advice
you have for others in choosing a boot
camp in the comment section down below
don't forget to hit subscribe and I will
see you next time bye